[Music]  I am attracted to Jafar yes the Disney  character when I was a kid my first  crush was a cartoon Peter Pan I was  devastated when I found out he couldn't  come out of the TV to marry me I've  always had a crush on adult Simba I  think he's sexy as hell I don't know  what's more messed up that he's a  cartoon or that he's a lion  I think Hades from Hercules was my  sexual awakening he was my first crush I  am attracted to Maleficent I can't get  past those big red lips I knew I was  bisexual ever since I was five  not only didn't like the Disney Princess  I was also attracted to Ariel Jasmine  Henson Gerber I find cars and sexy wild  and muscles my own mine every time I see  Beauty and the Beast I just imagine how  good sex with the Beast would be  [Music]  Wow  [Music]